فيروس كورونا الجديد الذي تم الإبلاغ عنه لأول مرة في
ووهان ، يواصل الصين انتشاره على
مستوى العالم حيث يتدافع مسؤولو الصحة العامة
لاحتوائه ،
وقد تم تأكيد عشرات الآلاف من الحالات في جميع أنحاء
العالم وقتل مئات الأشخاص
بسبب المرض ولا
يزال العالم يواجه الكثير من  عدم اليقين بشأن
كيف ومتى سيتم احتواء تفشي المرض ، تقوم
بعض البلدان بالحجر
الصحي واختبار مواطنيها للفيروس
إذا كانوا في
مقاطعة هوبي الصينية في الأسبوعين الماضيين قبالة
سواحل اليابان وهونج كونج ، سفينتين للرحلات البحرية
مع أكثر من 7000 شخص  تم الحجر الصحي على متن الطائرة
بعد
تشخيص إصابة الركاب بالفيروس ،
ومن المقرر احتجاز جميع الركاب لمدة 14 يومًا ، لكن
الركاب أخبروا شبكة CNN أن المعلومات
حول الحجر الصحي الخاصة بهم كانت بطيئة في
الوصول من أجل احتواء الفيروس ،
وقد أمرت الصين بإغلاق ملايين
الأشخاص و  وضعت غالبية
المقاطعات التي تم الإبلاغ عن الفيروس فيها لأول مرة
تحت الحجر الصحي في غضون
أيام شيدت الصين فيها  تم تعليق مستشفى wo
المخصص لعلاج فيروس
كورونا والمدارس في هونغ كونغ وماكاو
حاليًا ، لكن رد الفعل على
نهج الصين كان متباينًا
أشاد رئيس منظمة الصحة العالمية
بالصين لالتزامها بالشفافية على
الصعيدين الداخلي والخارجي وسط
تفشي المرض.  توني
خاصة لتعامله مع
المبلغين عن المخالفات د.  لقد ذهب لي طويلاً الذي
نبه الجمهور بمرض شبيه بالسارس
في أواخر ديسمبر / كانون الأول ، حيث تم
استجواب لي وتوبيخه من قبل الشرطة
قبل وفاته من المرض نفسه ،
وفقًا لما ذكرته
هيئة الإذاعة الحكومية الصينية CCTV في مستشفى ووهان المركزي
أن الطفلين حديثي الولادة في ووهان تم
تشخيصهما بفيروس كورونا.  بعد وقت قصير
من ولادته ،
أفادت CCTV أن الفيروس قد يكون
قد انتقل من الأم ، ولكن
دون مزيد من التفاصيل ، من المستحيل
معرفة ما إذا كان الأطفال قد أصيبوا بالفعل
في الرحم أو ما إذا كانوا مصابين بالفيروس.
تعرضت بعد فترة وجيزة من الولادة من خلال
الاتصال بالأم أو من خلال
التعامل مع العاملين الصحيين في جميع أنحاء آسيا
، تتعامل الحكومات مع
نقص أقنعة الوجه الطبية حيث تندفع الحشود إلى
المتاجر مع انتشار الفيروس وانتظر الناس
أربع ساعات لشراء قناع في هونج كونج
وجنوب البلاد.  تم منع المواطنين الكوريين
من ارتداء الأقنعة وفي تايلاند ،
فرضت الحكومة سعرًا ج
اتخذ الفاتيكان إجراءات بشحن
مئات الآلاف من الأقنعة إلى الصين ،
لكن مدير
إدارة المخاطر المعدية العالمية في
منظمة الصحة العالمية حذر من
أن صالون الأقنعة ليس إصلاحًا عالميًا
ويجب إقرانه بغسل اليدين ليكون
أكثر الأخبار فعالية.  اندلاع
الذكريات الشائعة لمتلازمة الجهاز التنفسي الحادة الوخيمة في Starr
والتي أصابت أكثر
من 8000 شخصًا وقتلت 774 شخصًا في عام 2003 ،
تجاوز عدد حالات الإصابة بفيروس ووهان
التاجي المؤكدة بالفعل
عدد النجوم
داخل بؤرة
الفيروس التاجي القاتل في صمت غريب في
شوارع ووهان  الصين هي مدينة يسميها 11 مليون شخص
منازلهم فارغة في الغالب ، ولكن حتى في
الحجر الصحي الذاتي مثل الحرب ،
استمر تشين في التحرك.أعيش في منطقة جينغو في
ووهان في بداية اليوم 21 عندما تحدثنا مع
وو ، إنه محظوظ فقط لوضعه ثلاث مرات
لم أفعل.  أواجه أي
صعوبات حقيقية في الحياة اليومية في الوقت الحالي
باستثناء أنني أشعر بالملل الشديد لأنني
مقيد في المنزل معظم وقته  قضى في
شقته مع نوبات قطته
توقفت عن الخروج من 13 يناير تقريبًا
لأنني أشعر أن الوباء
خطير جدًا وأنه من الآمن
نسبيًا البقاء في المنزل من الطهي إلى ممارسة
النظافة الجيدة ، حيث يسجل مصمم الجرافيك البالغ من العمر 26 عامًا
مقاطع الفيديو للحفاظ على أحزمة مسلية
الظهور عدة مرات مع
الأصدقاء ليس خيارًا حقًا كل
مجمع سكني حصل على أمر
بعدم السماح لأي غرباء بالدخول
ولكن من يتمنى أن يكون باقي
البلد أكثر فهمًا أن
ديميك ليس تحت سيطرة أحد ، أعرف
ربما الناس  الصين منحازة
تجاه سكان ووهان بالإضافة إلى أن الحكومة
لم تحل المشاكل في الوقت المناسب على الرغم من
أن عددًا صغيرًا من الأشخاص الذين سافروا
من ووهان ونشروا الوباء يتحمل جميع
مواطني ووهان اللوم الآن ،
ولا أعتقد أن هذا معقول  كما
ترون يا
رفاق يبدأون في الخروج إلى
هنا ، لذا سأحصل على بعض الطعام بينما أتيحت لي
الفرصة التي يمنحنا إياها المعلم الأمريكي جاستن
ستيف  شعور من
وجهة نظر المغتربين أنه ينتظر
الأوراق المناسبة لإجلاء زوجته
الصينية وطفلهما البالغ من العمر شهرًا واحدًا هو
والعديد من الآخرين هنا ليصبحوا
خبراء في السلامة الصحية بالمنزل ، الشيء التالي الذي
نريد فعله هو أننا نريد حماية العين
جيدًا.  لديّ زوج من
نظارات السلامة الطبية ، أمتلك نظاراتي المريحة
للعيون هنا والتي أحبها حقًا
داخل منزل وو فحصًا يوميًا
لدرجة الحرارة تليها لعبة
الغميضة وأعتقد أن
الوباء سيمر  وبالنسبة لنا نحن الأشخاص العاديين ،
كل ما يمكننا القيام به هو
الاعتناء بأنفسنا ، لا يزال اليوم 22 على بعد ساعات
، فأنا في قاعدة القوات الجوية التابعة للبحرية في ميريمان
لمدة 14 يومًا ، وحجر حبه
لليوم الأول ، ويُسمح لنا بفعل أي شيء في الداخل.
لكن لا يُسمح لي بالخروج
، ويمكنك أن ترى في الخلف هناك
خيمتان نصبتان في هذا المجمع
أننا نقدم أي رعاية طبية طارئة ، لذا
فهذه هي المرة الثانية التي أخرج فيها هذا الأسبوع
من الحجر الصحي الذاتي ، لذا دخلت أمي للتو
المتجر لاستعادة بعض الشاي
، هذه أمي حتى تتمكن من
معرفة أحد الاحتياطات التي أتخذها
هو أنني أرتدي قناعي حتى لو
لم أغادر السيارة ، فأنا لا
أصاب بأي شيء أو أي شخص مصاب ثم
أحمل معي أيضًا معقمًا لليدين
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى
] يظل خطر الإصابة بالعدوى بالنسبة للأمريكيين
منخفضًا ، ومن خلال هذه
الإجراءات وإجراءاتنا السابقة ، نعمل على
تقليل المخاطر